until the news now a 300 year old mosque
minaret has been demolished in Iraq
southern city of Basra to allow a road
to be expanded the toppling of this
saraji minaret and its mosque has
angered local people who say it's an
erosion of Iraq's Heritage Antiquities
officials say they did not permit the
Demolition and it should have been
preserved well we can get much more on
this from McMahon abdullahed who's in
Basra
put this into context for us I mean how
big a loss is this for Basra and indeed
the country
only if it's a major loss apparently as
you know this is a 300 year old mosque
and this man right besides it's a
symbolic men rate for Sunni Muslims and
Iraq it's the second most ancient mosque
in Iraq so besides its symbolism also
it's a unique uh architecture style now
many people here have been speaking to
locals neighbors here in Basra they're
they're so angry because the demolition
decision has raised uh or has parked
grief and anger among Iraqis across the
country as you know this is so symbolic
and because of the fact that they cannot
as people tell us here they cannot see
any strict measures in place to protect
such Rich cultural heritage so as you
know the the authorities here stand
behind the demolition of this mosque so
if I can just move out of the frame to
give you a larger picture of the scene
here behind me so what you can see here
is the rubble of the mosque but where
where is the Mini red the ancient
demolished minaret is just beneath that
rubble and the fact that it is
so unique because it it was
built from Adobe and mud and it lived
for centuries representing a unique
Islamic and a cultural art
and I mean it has clearly been
absolutely flattened I mean who's to
blame for the Demolition and how are
people reacting to it
well authorities here in Basra uh blame
each each other for the demolition the
the governor of Basra said that he has
taken the demolition decision after he's
taken approval from the Sunni or the
religious endowment the Sunni endowment
the one here in basa on the other hand
the Sunni endowment D1 said that refutes
that in fact and says that the
demolition decision is against what has
been agreed upon with the government of
basa they say that they have agreed upon
just carefully and gently dismantling
the minerit and move it gently to
another side of the mosque so they say
that they were stunned they were shocked
by the demolition decision as you know
that this is that used to be the the
second most ancient mosque in Iraq and
this minute which was about 11 meters
high as I mentioned represents a
three-year excuse me 300 year of
cultural heritage yes 300 years of
cultural heritage flattened in moments
many things